hey hello everyone
hey guys how you doing
it's so nice to see you i never you know
i think i realize now that after however
many episodes we've done 100 150
something like that
7 000 i think yes uh i realize i've
always said hello as if it's to the
audience and not really to you guys and
it doesn't really work i should be just
saying hello to you guys oh i thought
you were this whole time
oh no no never never i was never talking
to you
i'm inclusive but nicely
um
so uh
well
we have an interesting show for you
today possibly something that um may not
even have been seen before i'm not sure
uh but aaron who is the skeptic who um
who
uh was involved in who was the other
path of the
wiki letter conversation um with our uh
our skeptic mate andy
uh has agreed to come on and answer some
of the um things that we said in the
last podcast
um and not the last podcast i think it
was about two podcasts ago
uh so so we've got so very unusually i
think i don't think this i've never seen
this happen before um he's actually
going to come on and speak to us um
fair play to him and um
i like i hope that we will uh we will
place the the we you know the link to
this uh video underneath the previous
one so that people can see that he did
indeed answer to uh the questions that
we're putting to him uh it's kind of
brave of him and it you know it's it's a
bit unusual as well because there's
gonna be six people on the screen one
two three four five five people on the
screen
four of them will be men
which which as always isn't great up
isn't great optics for uh
because of what we're talking about um
but i'd like to step back just a little
bit and let helen take over on this one
uh if you feel up to it helen goes to
say that i can be loud enough for all of
us great it's great
um and um uh you know i just
basically what this is is like you know
our regular weekly show with the three
of us
and two skeptics who started a debate
online and are continuing it here
so um i think i think it's important to
say you know this is because this isn't
i mean this is just a show where we talk
about what's going on
these two
chaps have agreed to come on um i don't
you know i it it's a bit of like to just
play it by you and and and see what
happens it's just a conversation isn't
it so let's yeah yeah let's let's here
we go it'll be interesting i think
that's interesting because we've never
really done anything like this before
have a sort of like this is different
we're not chatting about a current
affair where
we're having a debate well not us but
we're we're inviting two people to have
a debate and you know i'm going to try
to stay out of it you know but i i don't
even know if it's that i mean they've
had their debate have that
yeah on the email i think this is more
to maybe talk i mean i'm interested in
how they felt that the the
even how the email format has has
actually worked have they got anything
out of it you know i think we should
just talk about it absolutely you know
that's not i don't i don't really want
to you know have sort of four people
putting one person on the you know yes
that's the other thing i don't him to
feel that he's being you know bullied so
so we'll play it as carefully as we can
there and if you're watching this early
and uh you know we will we will
hopefully uh give you a good chance to
um put your case um so we only have a
few minutes because it's going to be a
slightly longer episode or we're going
to concentrate on that uh to talk about
all the stuff that's been happening this
week and and you know as always in this
debate or this argument whatever you
want to call it it's just been packed as
always the latest i see is the girl
guiding finally got rid
of the fetish gear uh
rifle uh
enjoying
let's get you know leader um they they
did they get rid of the the tweet that
was advertising it or has he that person
gone they've dave said the results of
our investigation investigation are in
and the person has decided to
uh
leave of their own accord
so in other words
they wear you know in other words
parents can still not be sure
that trans-identified males are being
placed with young girls and girl guiding
and being called women as they do so so
you know girl guiding has gone exactly
the same route as the nspcc uh when when
safeguarding um uh problems were were
brought to them they blocked people
including me
uh for pointing out the story of the um
spcc worker who was masturbating while
at work or
you know on a work trip or something
um
and uh you know nspcc doubled down
blocked everyone called everyone bigots
and girl guiding are doing the same
thing uh you know they've blocked
everyone they haven't admitted they've
done any wrong and it doesn't seem to be
any suggestion they're going to change
their rules well there is that is very
much um you know and honestly i am not
sure that you can you can
blame them i mean it isn't it isn't a
particularly
integrity filled way of behaving but you
know it's it's the standard now for
people who are trying to push an agenda
through that they
know they can't necessarily answer to
they just you know
like you know it's turn off replies uh
it's just how it is isn't it i mean
you're just so used to people turning
off replies
it's just it's it's the only way this
this this um
it's the only way this uh this movement
can continue i noticed that every single
larger account that talks about
transitions they always turn off replies
you know and and the reason they'll give
for this is because they they'll say oh
you know my mentions will turn into a
bin fire or something like this and and
bin fire in this case means endless
endless endless endless
lines of women saying i'm sorry you're
wrong
saying my rights are important
saying men are not women or whatever it
happens to be yeah yeah i know i mean
like like like billy bragg you know i i
think i i made the point on on on
twitter you know he's come out to to say
sign this letter against the uh ehrc i i
mean which is incredible you know
now that now that they are trying to
balance rights uh people seem to have
gone insane and say that they are no
longer fit for purpose because they're
not just championing one lord of rice um
but billy bragg i think he you know
there are people who
maybe
don't you know do they just think oh
this you know they've jumped on the
bandwagon they haven't really thought
through all the issues but billy bragg
is not one of these people he has been
in it long enough and he must have heard
people or women reply to him up until
you know up until now he knows the
implications for women in this whole
trans thing and yet he has gone ahead
and he's saying you know oh support
support this so it's i mean it's he
really is he's showing his uh i think at
the contempt for the rights of women
there but
you know but does he does he address
them no it's just it's just done it's
it's like i support trans yeah yeah
uh arty sorry do you want to get
anything before i i start ranting again
no not yet okay
um i uh uh have been wondering something
with people like billy bragg i think
someone replied to it in wonder replies
and it it makes a lot of sense and i
think this is true not just brag not
just of those people like bragg and joel
and mom and people like that but i think
it's true of a wider group of people who
who simply will not get engaged in this
topic like i spoke to a friend recently
about this and i told him what was
happening and and it you know there's
been no follow-up no follow-up at all
you know and it's becau i personally
think it's because
so many adults are hostages of their
children in this debate
you know
like it was an interesting bit and i
don't know if you saw in the tony blair
piece
yes i did
it was interesting and he said that liam
had said to him just keep quiet dad you
know that uh there are emotions and
there are facts and and sometimes
emotions are more important than the
facts no he said at the moment at the
moment emotions are more important than
fact okay no i think that's fair to say
he said he wasn't necessarily condoning
it he was simply pointing out that you
know wading in to this this is what
you're gonna come up against yeah
let's say that let's say that tony
blair's son is at
a let's say a four on the on the
craziness thing and that he's aware of
the craziness but he's not necessarily
participating in it
um
uh
but there's many people whose kids i
would say are probably out of seven to
ten on the craziness uh front and i i'm
beginning to wonder whether the
the people who won't get involved people
who won't say anything the people who
are watching women get cancelled and
girl guiding get taken over and all this
type of thing and the homophobia and all
the stuff that comes with it i wonder
whether there's a kind of stockholm
syndrome thing going on with their kids
where their kids are telling them no you
gotta think this this is the right way
to everyone yeah i went i went out with
a group of group of women um lovely
local women uh last week and you know we
were all saying the same thing to to a
greater or lesser extent the kids are
there saying you know
don't make a fuss don't say anything you
know i don't agree with you and i'm
making life quite difficult for for
women to speak out i mean there's so
like
if this is all about preventing women
from speaking out or preventing people
from speaking out against it it is not
about making rational reasonable
arguments it's about preventing people
from opposing it and those two things
are really different i mean i don't know
if you i mean i think you saw earlier i
was really shocked to see
like
like on the other side of twitter
there's like
huge amounts of vilification going on um
about me at the moment you know to the
extent now it's it's ramped up but now
there's simply openly openly calling me
a sexual harasser and predator yeah um
and you know it's not because
anyone believes this like literally no
one believes this
um it's it's just a way to try and
silence me and obviously silence
women who associate with me and women
who believe the same thing you know it's
it's it's a massive massive coordinated
attack and it's you know but if like if
somebody could easily just come along
and say
yes to the question or no or even well
if somebody has had
gender confirmation surgery yes
otherwise no but this is not what's
happening no one will answer the
question and it's it's got to be to the
stage where they're so fudious that the
question still gets asked that it's it's
now about like
massive vilification
but just make an argument just make a
decent
to speak to aaron who is who has just
joined us in the uh in the reception
area um aaron if you don't mind i'm just
going to wait until andy arrives before
i begin it so thank you for for getting
here early um
can i just hop in and um helen was
saying it's really interesting uh the
wording that was tony blair who said
there are facts in our emotions
it was his son
that's such an interesting framing of it
because that touches on what i've been
saying a lot about the sort of the head
and the heart that people are have
passions and then they have reasons and
when you become when you're when you're
told to be passionate about something
you're led to be passionate about
something that shuts down your ability
to reason and your passions when you
decide that there's a tribe that's your
tribe so you need to protect and then
there's another that you need to attack
you know when you have an issue like
trans rights trans women or women
becomes your mantra
reason
you have to fight to shut down reason
and critical thinking because
it's entirely led by passions a lot of
these people who make these arguments
they're they're just all emotion and no
reason it's all angry chanting it's all
emotional arguments about danger and
safety is bad
oh no
no you're not about answering the
questions it's never about reason and
you actually the passion has to shut
down any attempted reason because
there's almost a sense that if you do
start to reason this you might find
yourself on the other side of your own
passions
you know yeah so reason becomes an enemy
yeah but i think it's it's more it's
more that it's it's very tribal isn't it
yeah you know
people find it very difficult to even
even question anything within within
that sort of tribalness
you know just even saying well maybe
there should be limits let's say maybe
let's have you know i believe that if
you've had gender confirmation surgery
then yes otherwise probably not
that you know that would be i think a
fairly reasonable answer that maybe
quite a lot of people would say but no
one will say it and i it's because
you know there is no there there cannot
be limits
because if there are limits then then
trans women aren't necessarily women's
health id doesn't work nothing works so
there can't be any limits so there
simply has to be a vilification and can
i just say to um everyone here in the
comments and on twitter thank you so
much that there's been some lovely
people just all really supportive and
and really nice um
and i and i appreciate it so much it's
it's it's just lovely to see well i was
i
i i i think uh the scottish actor's
tactic of uh misrepresenting video
backfired on him because he spurred me
to um re-upload
i'm not sure that that is is him that's
it's just somebody else who has found
that video and has made it i mean it
could be but who knows i have a feeling
it's him but but you're allowed to have
you know anonymous accounts and you can
say what you like it turns out
yeah yeah well unless you're unless
you're on our side well unless
[Applause]
hey andy if you're around can you join
us because aaron is here and it would be
great to get you in uh sooner rather
than later
um uh so uh
what else was oh yeah here he is
brilliant okay so listen andy and aaron
are here um andy is just
uh charging up or something hold on a
second
uh i shouldn't have announced early oh
here he is excellent okay
so uh i'm going to announce uh i'm going
to bring in andy and aaron now and uh
thank you again so much to them both for
agreeing to come on and do this hello
arab uh and hello andy lovely to have
you hi guys
lovely to have you on oh you're muted
erin sorry you're gonna have to if you
know it's all right okay you got it
great
hey thanks for having me on i appreciate
it
glad i finally found out this was
happening
yeah and i'm sorry i like i did i did
put a slightly snarky title to the last
youtube video which i will change
uh
now that you've you've turned up i guess
i guess really for us it's just kind of
so unusual to have someone come on and
actually speak about these issues
because
to be honest with you it's something
that we've been desperately trying to
have happen for years but no one will
usually speak to you because
i don't i mean i have theories about
that but let's not let's not go into
that let's start off um before we uh get
going on the on the video that we did
with andy and let's just quickly talk
about the format itself um
helen wants to one was wondering did you
find in the end that the format uh of
the wiki letter was a good one to use to
get to grips with some of these issues
uh let me ask aaron first
sure and this actually gets to one of
the first things that i wanted to
comment on from the last video as well
which was something that i think artie
in particular brought up about
you know
whether different mediums are a better
or worse medium for things like dealing
with gishkalap
i think you all were concerned that i
was engaging in gishkalop and the
suggestion was that in a live format
like this it would be harder for someone
like me to engage in that same kind of
tactic
this to me seems pretty backwards i
would say you know there's no format
that's perfect for preventing fallacies
but a format like letter wiki where i
can ask andy for the sources that he's
citing i can then go look at those
sources and check and confirm whether
they say what he says i can then come
back and say they don't appear to do
this can you you know provide different
sources or can you back this up in some
kind of way that's a much better format
i think for actually being able to slow
down a gishkalop as opposed to this live
format where i could throw off all sorts
of things and people just can't you know
address the vast majority of them so
i'm curious if you feel like that's
that's wrong or you have a different
assessment of these different mediums
andy what do you think
oh good grief yeah it's it was my first
time using wiki format or any sort of
format like that really uh you know
normally when we're engaged in
discussions skeptical discussions about
any sort of subject really it's um
obviously twitter is a very dominant
medium at the moment but before that it
was comment sections on blogs and so on
which is probably the closest thing to
it i imagine
uh
but uh it was between two people rather
than all and sundry piling in and trying
to yeah the discussion in
every way that you could imagine so
yeah it was um
you know it was uh
did it did
go on i'm so sorry i'm so sorry can i
can i just right at the beginning and
interject you i see people in the
comments asking um can we have a very
quick intro as to you know who you are
and
what you know what what happened yeah
sorry that's my fault i'm a terrible
host
andy would you would you like to do that
very quickly
yeah hi my name's andy lewis uh i um
started this exchange with aaron because
i've been in the skeptic community for
about 15 years ago now i i wrote a blog
called the quackometer and
got involved in a number of campaigns
you know social and political about
skeptical issues in the uk
and uh this is you know the the gender
ideology um
uh thing is something i've been thinking
about for the past few years but uh what
i why i invited aaron on was because to
talk to me
was not very many people in that
community are public about it or
speaking uh about it and that that was
uh
that interested me because lots of
claims are being made okay lots of
claims are challengeable
and that's what skeptics do they ask for
evidence they say what do you mean tell
me what you mean give me your evidence
and uh
and the key thing was you know why is
a lot of that not going on why is it not
going on
yes yes do you think he got to the
bottom of that era
so i would frame what we were actually
arguing about slightly differently
because i think it would be a trivial
claim to discuss whether or not we
should talk about trans issues i would
lose that argument merely by engaging
with it right if i show up to a debate
about whether we should show up to
debates about trans issues
right
i think we were arguing about something
more substantive which is whether or not
the tran the anti-trans or the gender
critical or the rad femme communities
are
uh under or dealing with a moral panic
in essence that they are contributing to
participating in knowingly or
unknowingly
a moral panic and that was
the original argument that you and i
believe were having online that was uh
sort of the central claim and in so far
as you know whether we address that i do
think that we you know i think that i
laid out a case for
why uh the evidence that you presented
makes one more likely to believe that
this is a moral panic rather than less
likely i know um helen in particular was
concerned that i opened with this idea
that it's a moral panic but i think
there was confusion because that to me
is the thesis statement right it would
be weird for me if i'm making an
argument to not open with my thesis
here's what i'm arguing for
right that would be duplicitous it seems
like i mean is that sort of what you
were saying there helen or how do you
address yeah so so so just for everyone
so who's listening could you very
quickly maybe please see
what the moral panic you you think is
happening is
sure so broadly speaking a moral panic
is a situation where
uh people who sometimes are very
genuinely concerned about something like
the well-being of children um
get information that leads them to
believe that either a non-existent or a
small
very small problem or a different kind
of problem is part of
this much larger
massive conspiracy-like kind of problem
where a bunch of bad actors are
deliberately trying to do something
nefarious essentially i think that
your community genuinely believes that
there is a massive conspiracy going on
around trans activism um and i think in
doing so
y'all are promoting
what what is very directly effectively
anti-semitic kinds of conspiracy
theories and things like that so that's
my biggest concern
well anti-semitic like i think is what
you're saying isn't it well no no and in
the case so
this is something that i want to get to
are you just laying out the argument
that we're bigots i just want to be
clear
no no i'm laying out the argument that
you are genuinely concerned about young
people and in doing so you are sharing
material
that is effectively arguing that
the trans agenda is actually a psyop by
jewish largely billions
yeah so so the specific example i would
link to would be glinner uh this is your
april 24th
article on your gliner update website
um it's you say well well well now isn't
this interesting and it's a link to a
transgender trend piece which links to
the arctis foundation grants article do
you remember this at all i do yes trish
does very good research
okay so in the first line of the article
she says the arctis foundation is
heavily invested in the dissemination of
transgender ideology to learn more about
this you can do nothing better than read
jennifer billick on this topic and then
she links to an article entitled rich
white men institutionalizing transgender
ideology are y'all not familiar with
that how many degrees of separation are
we at now
we're actually
no no aaron i want to go back to
something you said earlier on because i
think it really kind of um okay it
really centers in what the problem is
here the very first thing you did here
was you listed uh us as a group you said
we you know the gc or anti-trans we're
not anti-trans there are i don't want to
get into a debate about that i'll use
gender critical i'll use whatever term
you want to use no no no no no
because because as always you're you're
you're using words to to to impose
meaning on it the the this this movement
is not anti-trans there are plenty of
trans people who agree with us there is
debbie hey there's karina cole there is
uh
blair white there are plenty
no but i think this is actually much
more interesting this this whole this
idea that the gc as a whole now you've
said as a whole you haven't just sort of
said there's maybe like one or two
people in here who are right-wing or
anti-semitic you have said as a whole
the gc movement is anti-semitic which no
no no i've said they've shared they've
shared laundered anti-comics conspiracy
theory as a whole they all have like the
below would you like me to list all the
people would you like me to list
everybody no because
you would then have to list
literally thousands of women no no what
i'm saying is amongst the people like
glyner and helen joyce many of these
individuals many of these organizations
like the lgb alliance have all shared
jennifer billick's articles are you all
familiar with this individual do you
know what you're sharing like let me
genuinely ask do you know what you're
sharing
who i know
i just want to be clear about something
that doesn't make any sense this is i
mean what's happening here is that you
you you've come on and instead of
actually arguing any sort of substantive
point i'm happy to argue since the same
point i was in the middle of laying out
my position and you jumped into it
no because you just you just use
something that's completely off the
subject
no it's not okay it isn't even really
that interesting i mean honestly it's
not concerning to you that you're
sharing laundered anti-semitic
conspiracy theories
so are you saying that y'all are not in
favor of jennifer bellick's work on the
subject
aaron
i'm going to say that individual people
are allowed to say what they want
um but i'm just trying to help you all
understand why it looks like a moral
panic steeped in andy smith
yeah that's fine but it looks too i mean
i i'm genuinely skeptical that it
actually looks
like it to you i i
really you're wrong it looks more and
more to me like like a moral pain
everyone and saying oh i can maybe
cherry-pick an article
from here that this person has linked to
you and then this person has linked you
and then this person if you ask me for
evidence and i cite evidence and you
accuse me of cherry-picking there's
nothing more i can do you're just
refusing to look at me
i want to say something about this
jennifer billick did a lot of work about
a lot of things and then she afterwards
said something terrible and explicitly
anti-semitic i think and a lot of people
were quite appalled and moved to
distance themselves from her this is one
person
who's done something that a lot of
people have it's still up on your
website though
no
anti-submitted comments itself or a an
article that was posted previously by
somebody who later did something bad an
art an article an article that was then
written and then she engaged with overt
anti-semites like keith woods and shared
their material about this so what you're
saying let me just if i have ever cited
anyone who like hold on no no i want to
be clear on this please i know but none
of you would answer your questions
you all have asked 10 different
questions and none of you want me to
answer any of them right now please let
me answer this just
i don't want to get to the real
questions if i ever cite anyone who
later does something bad
later i have an obligation to go back in
time and find any reference i have ever
made to that person in any way
and remove it or i am endorsing what
they've ever done later on is that no
that's exactly what you're saying graham
decides
later it's not a question this is a
reporter no no no no i just want you are
saying that graham you want me here to
lecture me or do you want me to answer
any of your questions well right now
you're just kind of stalling to not hear
me no you all have been monologuing for
several minutes and i can't get a word
to explain myself
you've derailed this by accusing us of
anti-semitism you asked
about your position on allowing males
into female spaces now here's my
question
the wii spa incident in which a sex
offender entered into the wii spa
he he was acting according to california
law which allows men who identify as
women into uh into female spaces
is that
do women have a right to ask for male
body people to
leave female spaces in your eyes or do
they not have that right
right this as i understand it is a a
particular sort of thought terminating
cliche question that helen is very
familiar with so do you want me to
answer any of the questions or do you
want to interrupt me three seconds into
anything
answer this one
okay here's what i would say i think
that there is a complicated conversation
to be had about these sorts of spaces
and who should be allowed into them and
what the standard should be for an
individual to qualify as a woman and to
be allowed into these spaces i'm all for
having that complicated debate i don't
think that that is answerable in a
two-second two-line yes or no kind of
response which is what i feel like these
questions are built to try to demand
well why don't why don't why don't you
give uh an example of so say a male-born
person with a penis who
says that they're a woman do you believe
that they should be allowed to say into
female changing rooms with women and
girls because they have said that
they're the woman i think if we have a
system of experts that allows us to
assess
distinctions between legitimate cases of
an individual identifying as a woman
and what we can i think we can all agree
are some non-legitimate cases of
individuals identifying in this way
using some combination of
some period of time living as an
individual while taking into account
concerns around gatekeeping if we have a
system like that and they say the best
assessment the best way to deal with
this is this individual should be
allowed in these changing rooms they are
not going to pose a risk to anyone they
are not a threat they are not going to
try to use this as a a way to sneak in
and abuse people then that seems like a
fair solution to me
so that's right but what you're saying
then is you reject self-id you reject a
matter of trans women or women because
you reject no no no no anybody who says
they're a trans woman as a woman
no i think there's multiple ways to
understand self-id self-id means at the
end of the day as i understand it
there's no essential feature that we can
require that we would say makes someone
a woman themselves other than the fact
that they identify as such now we as a
society for various reasons may choose
to set up a system where we are going to
say
we will recognize self id as
this this experience in conjunction with
some amount of counseling or some
conjunction of
treatment or something like that as long
as it's not unduly burdensome to those
individuals and is genuinely reducing
you know uh the threat of a potential
risk
honestly
how on earth can you so so basically
like so should a teenage girl have the
right to say no i don't consent to this
person with a penis in addressing in my
space
again i think there's a complicated
question to be had
i don't think that we can just it's not
it's really not complex it's only
complicated if you don't think it's a
complicated question why are you asking
if you if you don't i don't understand
why you'd ask me for my answer if you
don't think it's a complicated question
i'm trying to i think it's a rhetorical
question
it's the answer of the
actually had to suffer through this how
many women have to suffer through this
is enough before you realize what
reality is wait great great can i can i
can i just say i i mean this is just
this is yeah it's not trolling i'm
trying to answer your questions and you
all are all losing your mind in response
oh yeah yeah yeah of course of course
we're just we're just ridiculous i mean
you all are y'all are like giving me no
time to explain my wh my view and when i
do explain it you then just accuse me of
not caring about women
helen can i suggest andy what do you
think it is so far where where are you
and all this
good grief about what question i think
about the first thing about conspiracies
i think it's typical that we're talking
about motivations for having an argument
about them the actual facts okay
motivations is always a very interesting
thing to talk about in skeptical circles
like someone might be anti-semitic or
something like that but that's only a
valid discussion to have we haven't been
talking about motivations i haven't been
accusing you of being anti-semitic this
is
i'm keeping tabs on who's interrupting
who and you're the number one winner
aaron so you're complaining that
everyone's not letting you talk but
you're cutting everyone off sure i'm
sure the audience can decide how this is
going so so it's an interesting
uh thing to discuss say in any
skeptical scenario whether it's about
homeopaths or chiropractors or whatever
trying to understand uh why they're
saying the things they're saying all
right about what their motivations are
um but it's only really a valid
discussion to have once you've
established what they're saying is wrong
okay or so for example if um
we're talking about that you know
puberty blockers are
not safe and
they shouldn't be
children can't give consent to to taking
them
it's a it's a fallacy to start accusing
anyone of being influenced by
some sort of uh
well let's say anti-semitism or
something whatever it might be okay
first of all you've got to establish
that that's a that's a reasonable belief
to hold or not and um once we go off and
talking about all these other things
we've just lost the plot i think really
to be honest so you know so for example
you know all this stuff about you know
helen joyce in a book trans and so on
she mentioned three donors to a campaign
in there two of which were jewish okay
she didn't mention they were jewish at
all in there and yet the whole
discussion about her book was whether
she was political or not and that's
ridiculous because no one actually
wanted to discuss and it's a deflection
from watching the book actually says
that's right which is uh quite a you
know a powerful poem about what is going
on here
uh so i i really just get fed up with
all those sort of arguments because uh
it's it's avoiding the central concerns
which is about
you know uh are we are we engaged in a
social
uh
like satanic
satanic cults or
what's it suppressed memory syndrome and
things like that all these things have
happened before is the transgender trend
for adolescents something like that or
is there something you know
real going on here that's uh
we've never uh heard of before and once
we accuse each other of being funded by
this that or that or whatever
we're doing those kids no no uh uh
service whatsoever that's what i think
thanks
i should just explain my camera's gone
so sorry about that um uh uh okay can i
respond yes please do respond there
okay
let's set aside for a second the
anti-semitism thing though i do think
it's important i'm not trying to accuse
you of being anti-semitic i do think
that it's important to understand
this background material but i want to
talk about this point about motivation
for a second because andy this was
something you said in the previous video
as well
that my arguments were largely about
motivation or politics now i don't
believe i accused you of any sort of
nefarious motivations in the letters um
and i don't think you know in fact quite
the opposite when i talk about moral
panics i am at great pains to make clear
that people who genuinely think they are
trying to help young people can still
get caught up in things like the satanic
panic not everybody in the satanic panic
had nefarious motives or something like
that um but looking
looking at the actual arguments that i
made in the letters right the first two
arguments were in relation like i said
two specific
disagreements with the data that you
cited right one was that it seemed like
your sources didn't actually have the
numbers that you were claiming they had
which we've gone back and forth on and
the other one being the fact that it
seemed like you were engaging in using
what i would call under contextualized
percent increase graphs right you were
using these percent increase graphs in a
way that i think is misleading and gives
the false impression of like runaway
exponential growth essentially
i think that that's a fairly solid
skeptical objection not an attack on
your motives in any kind of way but you
accused me of quibbling of engaging in
dishonest debate tactics which is an
attack on my motives rather than
addressing the actual claim so i can i
just ask right setting aside the
inconsistencies part can you understand
my concern about the percent increase
graphs that you were using in this in
the debate and like why i think that
they are indicative of a moral panic
rather than not i found it very
difficult to understand why you were
going down that route in the letter
exchange actually aaron because um there
was one particular figure about four
thousand percent which uh was included
in one of the references but not the one
directly underlined in the letter okay
and uh that seemed to derail uh to a
certain extent um
uh what i thought would be an
undisputable fact that the clinics like
um the tavistock in london were
reporting many thousands of percent
increases in referrals to their
pediatric gender services and no one
really had a good idea why this was and
that was something that needs to be
talked about [ __ ] now whether that
figure is four thousand percent
hundred three thousand and so on is
rather immaterial i think we could
quibble about whether one thing that's
why i want to focus on the percent
increase graphs where it left out the
fact that the thing leveled out so your
graph didn't include the most recent
data which shows that the increase was
leveling out
why not so i got a very good reason for
that okay because we wanted peer review
peer-reviewed research showing it so i
gave the uh the data that was peer
reviewed now the later data isn't okay
so it's from the same sort of from the
same people yes ah yes but there's the
raw statistics that come from the clinic
which are not peer reviewed okay and
that's the papers that discuss i think
so if it turned out that those numbers
were peer reviewed and turned out to be
consistent would you then say that there
was no longer this fear of exponential
you know uh catastrophic uh whatever
problem well we're still up in the
thousands of percent increase from from
uh
right but no different than that
it's okay are you suggesting aaron that
if it's gone up tenfold but it's not
continuing to go up tenfold it's fine
that it only went up tenfold as long as
it's not still go as long it doesn't
matter that there's ten times more than
there has ever been as long as it's not
a hundred times tomorrow like right
is that what you're saying like as long
as it's not astronomic it's still going
up then it's fine it's just like it
never went up in the first place it's
not the only data point we need the
other data point we would need would be
things like how much has it gone up in
proportion to what our theoretical
likely number of individuals in the
population actually is which is another
statistic that was left out of andy's uh
chart and which shows that like that
percent increase doesn't suggest that
the number has gone wildly beyond what
we would expect to be the actual number
estimated number of of trans individuals
uh in society so it's similar to like
you know you see a massive increase in
left-handedness in society right and we
ask is there a contagion of
less-handedness or is it just that we
stop beating people for being
left-handed and similarly right you know
we see a large increase in the number of
gay people the number of bi people we
even see as i cited in one of the charts
a differing increase where there's more
women who it seems to be are coming out
as bi than men but it doesn't seem like
we're arguing that there's a massive
social contagion around bisexuality in
which aaron aaron that's because
bisexuals and left-handed people don't
cut off their breasts or
that's not an argument against
it doesn't matter because we're still
trying to figure out if there's a
problem and if there's not actually a
problem in terms of the population
there's a problem there's a problem if
there's one person doing it andy please
do andy yeah
what would i say was to be frank you
know when i introduced this we had a
little bit of exchange uh behind the
scenes about whether we should be
referencing what we're writing or it was
just an informal chat and to be frank i
really did not expect to be challenged
on
what many clinics are reporting is this
huge two orders of magnitude at least
it's not it's not that i'm challenged
because there's an increase though yeah
yeah so okay so i thought that would be
a given fact that we didn't have to
worry about arguing about now you're
confused about what we're arguing about
it seems like yeah i'm not arguing with
that
i'm going to have to cut you off keep
interrupting them okay okay so you came
back and said
uh it's a skeptical fallacy to show
charts that are unrelated to any
baselines or whatever or whatever like
that and you introduced something i
think it was for reports of being
lesbian or something like that which
only i can't remember was it 30 or 40
increase or maybe even a 10 times
increase we're talking about several
orders of magnitude change here and
what's more than that a complete change
of demographics of what's occurring in
these hospitals where for example there
were just no case studies whatsoever
of young girls occurring you know
turning up to clinics like this with no
previous history of dysphoria and
wishing to transition it was unheard of
and yet all of a sudden we're seeing
this is the dominant
dominant presentation in many of these
clinics
i didn't think that that would be
challenged and i found that incredible
that you did because it stopped us
discussing what the actual reasons for
that would be properly yes i think
that's true i i guess
no i guess i'm surprised because you
went into it with like the numbers
matter you know like facts matter and
that sort of thing and so i asked you
for numbers and then i showed why it
seemed to me that your numbers didn't
show what you were actually arguing for
and you seem to be confused about what
i'm saying and instead thinking that i'm
saying the numbers don't prove that
there's been an increase i agree there's
been an increase i agree there's been a
substantial increase i don't think
you've given evidence that there is an
increase that shows that there is a
social contagion that this is out of
control in some sort of harmful kind of
way and that when you make those claims
i didn't make those claims it was out of
control what i said there was a massive
new phenomenon that we needed to so you
don't think this is an out of control
social contagion well so okay we we i i
didn't make that claim there but i think
whether it's out of control or not i
think social contagion is probably the
a dominant explanatory factor for what's
going on here absolutely i think it's
the only one that makes sense using
nothing's razer it's the simplest
explanation
uh do you think this social
communication also explains the
by the by chart as well uh oh
well no i think that probably is exactly
what you say i think it's social
acceptance but but that doesn't explain
what's going on here because
uh people coming out as bi or
left-handed it's not focused on this
narrow
13 to 16 year old cohort mostly girls
okay who are chatting to each other on
tick tock or whatever the fashionable
thing is okay so um it doesn't have the
explanatory power to describe what the
clinicians are seeing social contagion
and no one has generated any data to
show that that might be the case
the only data that we have to go on is
this hotly dispute disputed litmus
papers okay which
although they are preliminary papers and
because of that they are
you know they're not going to be
conclusive okay
that is the only data that we've got to
go on and i would welcome other
researchers having a go and trying to
show that it's whatever their hypothesis
whether it's social contagion or
um social acceptance or you know or a
virus you know who knows what hypothesis
what they could come up with okay
but the data isn't there and one of the
reasons is because as soon as people
research this they are hounded they are
absolutely handed by activists to be
told they're transphobic what we should
be doing is accepting these children and
pushing them down the sausage machine as
quickly as possible to transition them
and i think that's that's a moral
disaster that's happening in our society
and it really is
let's hear it aaron sorry what do you
say okay sorry yeah
so
a moral disaster do you do you do you
disagree with andy
let me talk now so i would say i think
it's unlikely that we are engaged in a
moral disaster right i think our our two
theses are currently under determined on
some data in the sense of as you say we
don't have enough data on things around
desisting and detransitioning we need
more information about so like if you
all are correct for example it seems to
me correct me if i'm wrong here in the
next five years or so we're going to
just be inundated with stories of just
horror stories of people being miserable
i know you all have you know some
stories already but i mean like on a
large scale there should be like mass
lawsuits or massive
like a huge collapse of of what is uh
apparently it seems like a really
harmful
medical state or something is that
accurate to y'all's views yes i'd say so
so if in five years from now that hasn't
happened if in like five years from now
we still are in the place where like the
majority of people who transition it
seems like as far as we can tell
are happy
and like we're not seeing massive
lawsuits or something like that with
that it suggests you that maybe this was
a overstated concern
well there's another possibility that
i'm not sure that you've responded to
what andy was saying there i think
you've asked now questions of us
i mean i think andy's made an excellent
point here about the best explanation
that's going on right now is the
solution contagion
but your response is to ask us about
five years down the line
my response is to build on andy's point
i'm building on andy's point here and
saying i agree with him that we don't
currently have enough information i
think that the evidence leans more
towards it not being a social contagion
that it being the kind of social
acceptance and greater access that uh is
similar to previous kinds of moral
panics like the uh you know the moral
panic over gay agenda or things like
that um but i think you know at the end
of the day there is something to be said
for at the you know we're gonna get data
on this one way or another if y'all are
right that a bunch of people are being
fed into a transition machine that they
shouldn't be fed into then we're going
to have a bunch of proof of that and
it's going to be terrible i feel bad
that like those people have gone that
experience i'm like i don't want to
discount that at all but what i'm saying
is i don't think we can for sure one way
or another confirm this until we
you know have a little bit more
information on that front my belief
having looked at things like the litman
studies is that the evidence for this
theory is not good and the
claims about what we mean by a social
contagion slide from a more robust
people are being pressured into this or
psychologically and you know coerced
into it in a way that is unhealthy
rather than people are simply gaining
access to more knowledge about this
issue right then why do you explain so
can i can i can i ask can i ask so but
but there's a difference isn't that i
mean
we
i mean there there simply isn't like
when i was a child trans just it just
wasn't a thing for girls like it's not
that you know we
like me even and hundreds of thousands
of women that i know
we were very much um of the
idea we want to be tomboys because that
being you know being brought up again in
the 70s you know it
seemed very restricting you know it was
girls who this boys do this but there
was you know and we we had this idea
that we would much prefer to be boys
because boys seem to have more freedom
but the idea of actually being about
actually being trans simply didn't exist
this is a new
idea
and and obviously as this new idea has
come along people are picking up at it
and saying yes that's that's me but but
that's because the idea is is there and
they can and they can grasp onto it and
say yes that that explains me but it
does but
it didn't use to exist so this is
obviously being passed along
socially i think i think the biggest
problem about if that's
if that's the social contagion argument
though then that's a trivially true
claim and applies equally to
homosexuality applies to every other
social change
i'm a gay man i really want to thank you
okay felt attraction they felt
attraction to the same people actually
felt i think various versions of
non-identifying with their body in ways
too they didn't have the language for it
but like but saying we didn't have the
language for it doesn't mean that their
phenomena didn't exist
oh i'm a gay man can i can i bring arty
go
yeah i'm a gay man who experienced
dysphoria as a child i wanted to be a
girl i know about the feeling of feeling
disconnected from your body and i know
what it is to grow up with that so the
outcomes of either being disconnected
from your body and going through surgery
losing 20 years of your lifespan from
all the medical intervention on your
life and spending the rest of your life
as a medical patient versus coming to
terms with your disconnected feelings
from your body throughout history people
have been same sex attraction and that
number hasn't wavered we can we can see
this through studies though obviously
more people are out of the closet now
than used to be and throughout history
some people have been gender
non-conforming some men have been very
feminine and throughout history you know
some men have felt that they wanted to
be women with the idea but most of the
time they got over it and dealt with it
the idea that if you feel that way even
temporarily you should be put into the
sausage maker is a documented phenomenon
that was invented in the 20th century we
know this for a fact you keep making
comparisons to homosexuality we know
that homosexuality has existed
throughout time immemorial
trans is a thing that has been invented
documentedly in the 20th century the
western concept of trans and it's being
reinvented and refined and redefined
every day so this idea that you keep
making these suggestions that there's a
sort of natural baseline of a certain
number of people who innately are trans
that is factually demonstrably not true
where is there are a certain number of
men who are feminine there's a certain
number of women who are masculine there
are a certain number of men who are just
really really turned on at the idea of
having a female body which is the
baseline for for male to female sex
change is sexual paraphilia of course
that's also documented and factual so
this idea that this is an innate thing
is just false and we've got demonstrable
numbers ken zucker did a study you take
a bunch of little boys who want to be
girls who are distressed that they're
boys
half of them you'll tell them they're
really girls half of them you tell them
they're just boys and you see what
happens when they grow up and all the
ones you told them they're really girls
they end up transitioning and all the
ones you told them oh they're not really
girls it's okay you'll get over this
they end up not transitioning and doing
just fine and ending up probably gay
there are some exceptions on both sides
some of the boys you told them they're
really girls they got over it even still
and said oh i guess i'm just a gay guy
and some of the boys you told them
they're not girls they never got over it
and they decided to have sex changes
later on but we know if you raise a boy
who thinks he's a girl that he is trans
he's gonna end up most likely trans and
if you raise a boy who thinks he's a
girl that he's just feminine and that's
fine and he's a boy he's gonna end up
not trans we know okay let's get it to
respond yeah let's get the response yes
sure so i mean i'm not an expert on
either the history of sex or gender
though i do think it's more complicated
than you're suggesting there in terms of
the evolution of these categories and
people's understanding about these sorts
of issues um but i want to really focus
in on what you were saying there about
like you you basically it seems to me
want to say we don't want to give people
the choice or we want to seriously deter
them from the choice of
medically transitioning because it will
be harmful to them and it's just playing
into an ideology and that they'd be
better off just not do you want them not
have access to that medical technology
or
children who are too young
i'm talking about
i'm curious either actually i am talking
about children if an adult wants to make
that decision that is fine as long as
it's an informed decision we are talking
about doing this to children before they
have even reached puberty there is an
absolute race to get this into these
kids as quickly as possible you know so
what i think is that we have a complex
ethical problem where
we have a situation where we have some
proportion of individuals who
i think identify as trans and i've known
some who identify as trans pretty from
fairly early on um and who i think would
benefit from avoiding going through
their assigned at birth
gendered puberty uh and transitioning in
such a way where they don't have to wait
until after that process and into
adulthood to do that that is a very
ethically fraught issue i teach
bioethics and i don't i don't want to
undercut the severity of this question
of how do we treat these young
individuals i just don't think that we
can say
we should ban all such individuals from
having access to that kind of medical
treatment just because you're concerned
that like some of them will potentially
regret it and will suffer some costs as
a result the problem is
medical care with children always
involves these complicated questions of
consent and the best we can do is
respect their
autonomy to the best of their abilities
at their age combined with you know
genuine support
okay on that i just need to you know no
uh the id so you're conceding that it's
possible that there could be some
problems with pediatric transition you
don't want an outright ban but you can
see that it's fraught with ethical
issues but then you throw in some words
everything is fraught with ethical
issues yes but when i make a claim that
there are problems
could you do you agree then that you say
respecting children's autonomy that's
already kind of dubious because we're
we're working in fuzzy shady stuff here
when we know that children are being
influenced by social media and social
contagion and peer issues but you at
least concede that in between a total
ban on children uh ever getting any kind
of pediatric transition and in between
the sausage factory that we're at now
you at least can see that what's going
on now has the potential
to be causing a lot of problems given
that it is a fact i mean i would reject
your description of the current
situation but as well we have 21 000 d
transition young people already you said
before that if in five years time we
have a crisis of outrageous numbers of
detransitioners would would you change
your mind we don't need to wait five
years we've got 21 000 harmed young
people already today you know you have
to look at the statistic
that's sort of like
it's not peer-reviewed evidence yet
certainly pointing in the direction that
we're absolutely
and he's right that we should certainly
be consistent in our demands for
evidence right but
what i think there was a really really
big problem here at the moment is that
anyone wanting to do any research in
this area um get sent death threats okay
that is completely out of control
but like at the end of the day everybody
on both sides gets sent death threats no
they don't i got a bunch of harassment
just for having a letter wiki with you
i know but that's true from yours
you said you said no from your side i
got no harassment from my side and then
you said harassment it's very very
different right you know there's there's
you you can say i mean this is this is
very much a modern bailly argument isn't
it where you say death threats and then
you say well i've got harassment like
have i spoke means anything nowadays
what i'm saying is that transitions
did you
focus on how many let's focus on the
real problem here
researchers can't research this yes okay
my point is they can lisa littman is in
the middle of researching this right now
she's not being prevented from
researching she got sacked from her job
but she's still doing research like what
i'm saying is
is that this is so is such a toxic
environment because of your side i'm
afraid aaron that scientists and
researchers can't do their job without
having hounded out of it here's what i
think i think every conspiracy theorist
community in the world claims that when
they try to get research done on their
thing it gets suppressed and you know
people get attacked and so that's why
the evidence for their theory doesn't
exist and and here's the thing i can't
prove you wrong or right because the
evidence doesn't exist i disagree with
you generally
it does exist in the firing of lisa
i don't think the fireworks
what about what happened to michael
bailey what happened to michael bailey
he was sent his his children were
targeted what happened
got harassed
so if i pointed to examples of your side
i mean if i put into examples of people
in this room what doing what seems to me
to be harassing behaviors does that
discredit the arguments from your side
go ahead i'm curious to see this
no actually no i mean because because i
think you know it seems like a terrible
argument right helen
well i just the argument you're making
is oh technically you can still do
research but you're gonna get you can
you'll get fired for doing it but you
could technically still do your research
except she's still doing research like
she's still getting funded for doing it
i'm sure she gets plenty of support for
doing it yeah like what i'm saying is
you know we can look into the details
and i'm sure the details of her firing
are more complicated than than we're
putting on the table here no no she made
it clear she got fired for this 100
and and did the did the uh
place she was fired from get to respond
what did they say in response they said
they were already renewing her contract
and then they said they couldn't renew
it after the controversy so she already
knew that she had been renewed and she
had continued employment and then the
controversy happened and then they said
they had to pull it so the evidence is
there you know okay i mean
it's quite plausible
anything wait because but but look at
this no we here we like immediately we
started talking
your reply here your your your opening
gambit was that we are anti-semitic i
mean right like again all right let's
come back to this let's come back to
that i have not accused we have not
accused you of anything like that
your immediate opening gambit was you're
not anti-semitic and that is nothing
except that that's all that is used for
is to try and shut people down
no
let me be clear
let me be absolutely clear about this i
have not yet said anybody here is
anti-semitic in fact i've made quite
clear that i do not think that you are
anti-semitic you keep reframing what i
was saying which is
individuals including graham and many
other people in your community have
shared anti-semitic conspiracy theories
i think unknowingly i don't think you
all seem to understand okay so let's
just clarify anti-semitic adjacent
because we're anticipating
conspiracy theories by doing that that's
a bad thing you should think it's a bad
thing to be sharing them even
unintentionally yes but but people share
ideas that i'm actually a sexual abuser
for asking a question about male-bodied
people with a penis i mean that's just
is your argument because someone else on
the internet did something bad it's okay
that you did something bad
no
what is the point of your argument there
i might what is my argument is that you
are the one that is arguing that people
have done bad things i'm saying let's
talk about people's arguments in terms
of their arguments let's not start by
saying what i'm saying this person is
anti-semitic or look they share
anti-semitic theories like i'm not
saying oh your side shares ideas of me
and other women being texting let me try
this one more time
all right let me try this one more time
right my thesis statement is y'all are
engaged in a moral panic okay
one of my pieces of evidence for that is
like with other moral panics y'all
appear to be knowingly or unknowingly i
think unknowingly sharing what i think
we all agree is
these conspiracy theories wait in the
plural so you've got multiple examples
not just one that's four degrees of
separation right yes i have multiple
examples
no not just jennifer billick over and
over again though
i'm sorry why does it matter if
everybody agrees to share the same
anti-semitic conspiracy theory rather
than different people's sources
i mean who is everybody do you want the
list
i haven't ever shared any
i hope you've got your lawyer ready
again i have i have all the evidence for
where this stuff was shared by people
like graham by the lgb alliance here's
the other people alison bailey has also
shared the article from billet
sheila jeffries also shared the article
an article or a separate article by
somebody i would argue that the original
article is the anti-semitic article and
then she she then
uh well because she specifically focuses
in and argues that these jewish
billionaires are secretly waiting
jewish billionaires or justices
three people two of which were jews so
here's what happened actually right she
originally says
genuinely i am so uninterested in a
conversation that just goes on and on
about
yeah it's just like it's weird that you
don't want me to actually explain myself
i just think it's interesting
we've got you
again but so but i would actually before
before we before we leave i would
actually quite like to go back to where
we were on um women's spaces because
there's a lot of women here and for us
actually it's the children and the women
that matters the matters
um and so so so back to the idea so
teenage girls are women and girls that
go into a changing room are you
suggesting that they should
not
now have the right of bodily autonomy to
consent
to who
to to to
only be sharing spaces with with other
women are you saying that they should
not have this right anymore that
a certain proportion of male 1 people
with a penis should be allowed in
i think that rights are complicated like
all the ethical discussions and i think
that
what they actually originally had was
being part of a community where we
were segregating spaces for a variety of
reasons one of which is potential
concerns about safety
and we are taking that factor into
account but it isn't there's no sort of
binary about whether they have an
absolute right or not it's more like um
you know
women uh
may feel genuine concern and that
concern should be taken into
consideration it may not be
determinative but it is not totally
meaningless and it should go into our
social considerations about how dr how
best to address things like women's only
spaces
oh and how do you think
how is a young woman who is on leah
thomas's swim team supposed to at what
is her right when leah thomas walks
around naked in the changing room
does she have the right and should she
be and should her right be observed
should it be honored to ask him to leave
the the changing rooms is leah thomas
wandering around naked in changing rooms
yes
okay it's been reported in the stories
yes with a penis yup
i would say that they are
i think it's worth having a conversation
about it like i think the human thing
here's what i would say right that's
what i'm saying i think the human thing
to do is for her to say you know i don't
feel comfortable about this and for them
to say
let's address this and there are
multiple ways that they could address it
which could be she doesn't you know that
she doesn't walk around in that kind and
again i want to i want to caveat i'm not
coach has said they are not yes or no
yeah i would say the answer is here's
the problem
yes or no answers and that's just not
how reality works no i'm afraid it is
when it comes to safeguarding aaron you
know
to have access to children when they are
private vulnerable and negative if
that's your view there's no point in
engaging with people like me because you
don't care what my answers are you're
just waiting to dunk on the lack of yes
or no answers yeah but you're jumping
over the changing i think the problem
with the changing room is that it is i
mean it is binary isn't it you know
the door is either open or shut you're
one side or the other so you know should
leah thomas be allowed in to a communal
changing room where where girls are
actually just undressing in a community
they're not in stores should the
autonomous be allowed in
um as not only you know to
expose his penis but though you know he
can actually
see those girls you know those girls are
now under a male gaze and it's you know
which in this society is just awful you
know in terms of porn etc so
should do you
personally think that leah thomas should
be allowed in there
yes
okay that's actually i'm actually
impressed at that that is um really
really interesting
um okay listen uh i'm gonna have to go
because my um my son is uh is is coming
up to visit so i'm gonna have to cut
this short
can i can i just very quickly say um
i i do appreciate that you answered that
because hardly anyone will but you have
now made it clear very very clear that
trans activism here is is is really
trying to override the consent of women
and girls i mean this is you are the
trans activist you i disagree surely
actually believe
that that this this person should be
allowed in with women and girls and i do
appreciate you saying it out loud
because hardly anyone will do it so
thank you for that so so i disagree that
that's what i actually did uh you asked
me for my all things considered ethical
conclusion i gave it i think the
situation is more complex than your than
your thought terminating cliche brings
about in people's lives
because you just you just want to hear
that the answer is no and that's the end
of the conversation rather than actually
discussing the questions
he said i'm really pleased to hear you
say yes i really am fair enough yeah i i
disagree about what it means but yes i
think ultimately people who have not
fully physically transitioned should be
allowed into these spaces in certain
situations
of this one but i think generally
speaking yes
you're saying men should be allowed into
these spaces okay individuals assigned
male at birth should be allowed into
these things
yeah biologists here folks violence
aaron
anyways thank you very much thank you
again it's nice to see uh both of you uh
turn up thank you very much thank you
andy and sorry we didn't thank you
everyone thank you and thank you andy
all right yeah speak to you soon bye bye
bye
all right uh right okay
that's that's how it goes down it always
gets really really ugly really honestly
i was a bit worried that it would go
that way i mean i didn't think either
can i just say can i just say though
there's people in the in the comments
who are complaining about us having them
on you know like we we can't you know
please everybody we genuinely wanted to
have a conversation about this you know
it was it was like very revealing in a
number of different ways um and i think
that final moment was extraordinary
um where he actually said yes that was
you know i i think yeah
yeah i mean i was
like we were a bit worried that it it it
could it would sort of degenerate into
having somebody sort of you know
basically
had you know trolling a bit i mean he
did he did i think sort of libel some
some some women there or slander some
women there which i'm really not
particularly happy with um i thought
andy was very good very very measured
very calm i like andy very much so you
know
every time we give him a question he'd
be like well that's an interesting
question worth debating and it's like
yes you're in the debate
well i think that was quite interesting
in itself wasn't it i mean
i think but you know to be fair there
were four of us and it was one of him so
yeah that's that's why in the end it it
it was a tough old thing i wish i had
that's why it degenerated and it wasn't
even really very good yeah i i actually
i actually wish it you know sometimes i
i we were thinking of of just having uh
having uh andy and and aaron on and me
but then that would have been three men
talking about it so it's just you can't
win you cannot win with this stuff um uh
listen that was uh that was uh that was
really great i think that despite
everything i think it revealed a lot
about the uh motivations of the people
on the other side yeah psychology at the
other side is really interesting isn't
it so there's i know this was a
frustrating episode but we're really
getting some insight into what's going
on in the other side's mind why they're
not seeing what we're saying they show
us this is their argument and it's it is
shocking you know um and it's you know
it but at least we're seeing it maybe we
should do an extra mess on the weekend
and uh so we can just you know get it in
the air clean our heads
exactly exactly yeah all right guys i
gotta see my son so i will see you very
soon
hang around for a production meeting
after this guys just for a sec
lovely to see you all thank you all for
the comments speak to you soon bye